problems this uh joint work with richard
kuhn
giacomo torlai victor albert and john
brasco
so recently machine learning has
received a lot of attention in the
quantum community these days
in particular one of a goal for applying
costco ml to quantum physics and
chemistry
is to solve challenging quantum media
body problems using ml
that could potentially yell solution
better than traditional classical
algorithms
however despite the interest many
fundamental questions remain to be
answered
in particular a key question that should
be addressed
is how can machine learning algorithms
be more useful than non-machine learning
algorithms
in solving these kinds of very
challenging quantum many body problems
so in this talk i would provide some
concrete answer
to answering this question so here's the
outline
of today's talk first i will provide a
very brief review on classical shadow
formalism
and then i would dive into discussing
two tasks
training machines to predict ground
state and to classify quantum phases of
matter
so the main question that classical
shadow formalism trying to address
is how can machine learning how can
classical machines see quantum many body
system
and by that what we actually mean is the
ability to convert
a quantum media body system to a
classical form
that accurately captures many properties
of the quantum system
in this talk we would basically focus on
classical shadow that's based on
randomized healthy measurement so in
this form of classical shadow
when you're being presented with some
quantum system what you do is you
perform
you you perform single qubit random
clifford rotation on each qubit and then
you perform a computational basis
measurement
which allows you to gather
and that constitutes one randomized
penalty measurement so essentially when
you perform one randomized penalty
measurement
you get essentially n outcomes
and for each of the outcome so basically
each outcome corresponds to one qubit
and for each applied outcome you can
represent it using a two by two matrix
which we define as sigma t
high now if you just tensor product
all of these outcomes from different
qubits and then
average over the t randomized
measurement you get this
costco shadow representation sigma tr
which is an exponentially large random
matrix
with the property that an expectation
value this random matrix would be equal
to the unknown quantum state row
that you have created however a nice
property about it
is that it only takes older nt bits to
represent
and furthermore um while it's good on
expectation value there will be some
statistical fluctuation
so some of the properties given would
be subject to larger fluctuation and
then you wouldn't be able to preserve
them
or like estimate it using only sigma t
but there are several properties that
are actually preserved including
hamiltonians correlation functions
entanglement entropy
in constant sub constant size regions
as well as local observables that act on
a constant number of givens
yeah so now um what we're going to do in
the following talk
um every time we wanted to represent a
quantum say row we're just going to
represent it using this classical shadow
sigma tro
which only takes unt bits classical bits
to store which is very efficient
and preserve various properties
so now let me dive into the second part
of the talk so here we're going to
consider
provable primarily efficient algorithms
for predicting ground states
we represent some theory and some
numerical experiments
so the test that we are going to
consider here is that
basically what the machine has to do is
given a parameter
x which is a vector of dimension m
that describes some hamiltonian h of x
the machine has to
predict a classical representation of
the ground state
rho of x that corresponds to this
hamiltonian h of x
so you can think of this parameter x as
describing certain
um controllable parameters that the
experimentalists
could control when they're preparing
some physical system for example it
could be some
laser intensity that they could shine on
their quantum mechanical system
it could also be some description of the
view body interaction
in the material that the scientists have
created
or some magnetic field that they put
this block of material or this
chunk of physical hamiltonian in
that and
yeah and we're also going to assume that
the mapping from the parameter x
to the hamiltonian hfx is not known
exactly
which is pretty common in practice
because even for a single
x if you wanted to learn hfx exactly you
have to perform some kind of hamiltonian
tomography
which could potentially be challenging
like maybe you wanted to
first repair some thermal states of that
physical system
utilize this um algorithm proposed by
iwinter robinhotari and javanha to learn
the hfx but then you still didn't know
the mapping from xfx and
you have to try a bunch of different
acts and so on so here we're just going
to assume that
you haven't done that kind of
complicated process and
we don't know this mapping completely
and furthermore we're like i said before
we're going to represent the ground
state raw effects on a classical
computer
using its classical shadow sigma t of
raw effects
so more precisely what the machine
learning model would do is it would be
handed
a collection of basically a set of
training data which are examples telling
you that telling the machine that
for this parameter xl the corresponding
classical representation of the ground
state
would be sigma t row of xl so in order
to gather this training data
some complicated experimental effort has
to be made for example given a parameter
they might have to synthesize a new
material and perform some measurement on
the new material to get the
some classical representation of the
ground state so we are just going to
assume that
some experimental effort has been made
to construct this training data
and now what the machine learning model
has to do is given a new parameter
x that's not inside the training data
which will correspond to a
new material that the scientists never
synthesize in their
physical lab and then the machine
learning model has to predict the
classical representation
of the ground state efficiently using
the
new parameter so that's the
definition of the test and now let's
look at what kind of
machine learning model are we going to
look at so now given this training set
which is just a bunch of vectors mapping
to this exponential size matrix
we're just going to consider a machinery
model that
takes in an m-dimensional vector and
outputs an exponentially large matrix
sigma hat of x that would represent
sort of as a surrogate or a prediction
for the sigma t rho of xt
row of excel more precisely we're not
really going to do that but we're just
going to output an efficient
representation
of sigma head of x in particular we're
going to
assume or we're going to enforce that
the machinery model
has to be trained within time that's
polynomial in system size
n and the number of parameter n
so so yeah so it indeed has to offer
some representation of sigma hat of x
rather than the raw representation which
would take exponentially
benefits to store
so to give a better sense of what kind
of machinery model
we are dealing with and how we could
efficiently train it that supposed that
we wanted to train a neural network
that's illustrated below so it has an
input layer consisting of
m neurons and an output layer consisting
of exponentially many neurons
so two to the m by two trillion so
basically it just outputs the
exponentially large matrix so it looks
like this kind of bizarre
the large model cannot be trained
efficiently but
utilizing recently so basically we
showed that based on
recent results and neural network theory
this training can actually be done
efficiently in particular you can show
that if you have this kind of
big neural network that take in and
this m-dimensional vector so represented
here as sigma hat
w which takes in some m-dimensional
vector
and outputs this exponentially large
matrix if you
train the machine learning model to
minimize this cost function
so basically it's just the output of the
machinery model
minus the the classical shadow
representation which is also an
explanatory large
matrix the forbidden storm square and
you sum over the
entire training set if you perform a
gradient descent
on this cost function you can show that
after training
the neural network actually has a
analytical form
written in the right hand side where
this kappa and then
would be some learned function that
depends on the neural network model
as well as the training set which can
also be obtained efficiently
and that kind of formalism doesn't only
hold for
your networks but a variety of machine
learning models such as kernel methods
which will be
also talked about i think in the in the
next talk um
this kind of uh of this kind of
machinery model you can show that
um the global optimum after optimization
have this form
when you train on this training set um
excel mapping to sigma t row of xl
particularly what it's doing is pretty
easy to understand
you should think of this kappa as a
function that tells you
how you should extrapolate from the
training point to a new point
that's not in the training step so for
example if you have this x1 x2 x3 x4
what this formula is essentially doing
is utilizing the
exponential large matrix associated to
each of this point
and just combining them through this
copper function to produce the
representation
for a new point x
so now as long as this kappa function
can be efficiently computed
then the machinery model's prediction
for the cost orbitation
of the ground state or a new point x can
be officially represented
using only an order of small n
times capital t times capital n so
recall that
all of the sigma t of this classical
shadow representation
only requires an order of small n times
capital t
fits classical bits to store so this
prediction
would also require very few amount of
bits to
um to soar efficiently on a classical
computer
and furthermore actually making
predictions about
um using this class orientation is also
easy
um as we have as a as due to this
linearity
straight
so now after talking about the machine
learning
model as well as the task the key idea
um
the key thing that we would like to
understand is what kind of theoretical
guarantee could we have
utilizing the set this cost of machine
learning
and for simplicity we were going to
focus on
an ml model where this kappa is
associated to an l2 directory kernel
so training such a ml model would be
closely related
to training basically trying to learn
in low degree fourier approximation to
this
matrix function row of x so the row of x
is the thing you wanted to learn
and essentially doing this would be
very closely related to that and now
theorem one shows that
utilizing this ml model based on l2
duration kernel
it will capture the ground state
properties accurately on average
in particular we proved that for any
smooth class of local hamiltonians such
as x
in some finite spatial dimensions so
we're thinking of a geometrically local
hamiltonian
such that it has a constant spectral gap
then given the number of training data
and that scales polynomially in m so the
small m
is the number of parameter so small m
could be
large or small it could be constant or
it could be polynomial in system size it
doesn't
really matter but the training data
would have no dependence on
the system size but only a dependence on
the number of parameters you have
and for each of the training point you
only need to perform one randomized
palette measurement
for each of them to construct this sigma
t
so it's just like a single shot random
matrix
in that case you can show that the
expected prediction error
when you wanted to utilize this
representation sigma of x
to predict any sum of local observable
would be upper bounded by a small
constant error
epsilon furthermore the training and the
prediction time
would both be polynomial in the number
of parameter and linear
in system size can i ask a quick
question
yeah what is constant spectral gap what
does that mean
oh it's constant with constant response
back to
m and n so the number of parameters and
system size but what is the
normalization on the hamiltonian like
what is the
is the norm of the hamiltonian boundary
the normal no no the norm of the
hamiltonian
could be extensive so it would scale us
linearly in system size
okay yes so i didn't normalize it so
it's like
like that can i also answer a quick
question
yes does the algorithm or the amount of
training data depend on the class
the algorithm or the amount
uh so the algorithm is basically just
this formula shown here
so it doesn't depends on the class and
the training data does
depends on the class so basically the
training data would be for that class
so you have a single smooth class of
flow components you get some training
data
inside of that and then you train the ml
model they perform
the number of the amount of training
data you need depend on some
parameters of the class oh it depends on
the spectral gap
it would also depends on the locality of
the hamiltonian so for example if it
acts on five
versus axon six six would be more it
would also depends on
like the inter the strings of the local
term
but here we're just going to assume that
all of them are bounded which i think is
a reasonable physical exception okay
okay
yeah intuitively this condition is
essentially saying that we're looking at
a
class of hamiltonian that constitutes a
quantum base
so that's basically what this constant
spectrum gap could be intuitively
startup
and to establish the theorem there are
essentially two key steps
the first step is it's the following
it's basically
utilizing the condition on having a
constant spectral gap
to imply some kind of a smooth condition
a smoothness condition
in a ground state space that is when
in this entire space the ground state
will not jump abruptly so like
so that's why you can intuitively think
of it as having a constant um
in the quantum phase so there's no sharp
changes in
the ground state and this could be
established by utilizing
the spectral flow technique and
re-droppings and bounce
so after establishing the smoothness
condition in the ground state space
you can prove that generation everything
for the proposed ml model utilizing this
l2 directional kernel
trained on this randomized measurement
data so basically
recall that all of these sigma t are
random matrices
um that consists of one randomized shot
so basically you have a
point xl with an associated ground state
and you do a randomized a single
randomized measurement to construct this
sequenti
so so yeah so basically you can show
that uh you can prove that gerundition
airbounds
for this kind of uh ml model um under
this
smoothness this guarantee so when when
the swiss is guaran
when we have the smoothness guarantee
from step one
we can show that the proposed ml model
would um have this kind of a
good generation error bound
utilizing some standard statistical
analysis
plus a realization that when you
consider
an m-dimensional constant radius
norm ball like a sphere the volume of
that would scale exponentially in
the dimension but actually the number of
lattice points
would only scales polynomially if you
set the radius to be constant
so that's another important part because
i mean that fact would
imply sort of the vc dimension of the
object that we're dealing with
and the vc dimension will be bounded
because the number of lattice points
in a m-dimensional sphere is polynomial
for a constant error and then we can
utilize that
to prove that generation area
so now one key limitation of theorem one
is that
i've explicitly said this epsilon can
only be a
constant and the reason is because so if
you fix epsilon to be constant
then the number of training data
actually only scales polynomially in m
but if you also consider epsilon to be
like super small then it would actually
scale exponentially
and note that we are considering a
classical machine learning algorithm
here so it's all classical
when i say the time it's all classical
computation time there's no quantum
computation
so one might wonder what if you train a
quantum machine learning model
what if you train like a quantum
learning algorithm
um could it overcome this kind of like
kind of uh
exponential scaling in the prediction
error so in one of our appendix
we proved that actually any quantum
as well as uh of course classical is
classical or quantum
any quantum machine learning occurs we
require a number of training data
that scales um similarly
to the scaling of this algorithm this
classical ml algorithm that we
considered
so essentially and the key idea is
similar is that
um the idea is that the number of
lattice points in the m-dimensional
sphere
indeed scales something like um
m to the power of one over epsilon so
there's just no better way because the
vc dimension
is just that large so even a quantum
machine
quantum machine learning algorithm would
not be able to
overcome it due to known results in
quantum learning theory
so yeah so basically what it says is
that the advantage
of a quantum machine learning model can
only be
polynomial um and can be never be like
explanation
so now after talking about how a
classical machine learning model
could be used to predict ground state
and have some rigorous guarantee
now we wanted to understand if a
non-machine learning algorithm
could also be due can also be used to do
the same
task in particular
in proposition one which is just a
combination of very standard results of
blockchain theory
one could easily show that if there is a
classical polynomial time randomized
algorithm
that could achieve like this average
prediction error of
one over fours for any one local
observable o
and for any smooth class of local
hamiltonians in two spatial dimensions
so note that previously it works for any
spatial dimension for example three
here we only consider two and also with
the constraint that we have a constant
vector gap
then you can show that a b complete
problems can be solved um
in randomized polynomial time which is
highly unlikely
and if you assume that rp is not equal
to mp opposition 1 tells us that
a non-machine learning algorithm cannot
achieve the same guarantee
as the machine learning algorithm
so going back to our original question
can machine learning algorithm be more
useful than non-machine learning
algorithm and why is that
the combination of theorem one and
proposition one tells us that
yes yes essentially yeah
uh sorry could you could you say what's
a non-machine learning algorithm versus
a machine learning algorithm
yeah so basically um what how i define
it
is that in the machine learning
algorithm you're allowed to be given
this training set
so you have a training data that you can
utilize
to okay but in non-machine learning
algorithm case we're assuming that they
couldn't learn from
data so it's just like a fixed algorithm
and that's where how we define it
and basically the key idea is just that
um in the machine learning algorithm
case all it has to do
is to take the data and generalize from
the data to perform computation
and that could be much easier like
significantly easier
than computing everything from scratch
so basically the training point
already solves the hard bits of the
problem and all the machine learning
algorithms doing is just generalizing
from the heartbeat to other new
instances the classical
if you don't have that data then the
problem suddenly becomes very hard
and that's why you have proposition one
and theorem one
so they didn't really contradict with
one another
in any way it's just the fact that if
you can learn from data
that's just more powerful so for example
if you can gather some data
from nature which operates quantum
mechanically so you can think of
the nature as being a quantum computer
and if you could gather some data by
performing physical experiments
that data would also contain some bqp
power
and may not be officially generated
using a classical computer
so in those kind of cases you can have a
classical machine learning algorithm
that could outperform a classical
algorithm that do not
utilize data so it's not yeah it's not
like a neural network is powerful or
anything it's just
the availability of data help
the computation
sorry i missed another thing could you
could you say robert what what
what was the distribution on the
yeah so the examples are sampled
uniformly at random
and we are also considering that the
prediction error is the same uniform
distribution
over the entire space
that's yeah actually that's quite
important um
i think uh similar results were also
seen in some kind of uh
like some learning of dnf or something
like that
or some learning of some function i
think uh ryan o'donnell
are probably more familiar i think there
are certain classes of
problems where it's easy with uniform
distribution
um but actually hard if you consider
arbitrary distribution
and this is actually one of them so it's
only easy
um like that is you can achieve uh
this theorem only under uniform
distribution if you consider some weird
distribution that are
that are localized at certain points and
so on then it could potentially become
much harder
so now i'll just briefly go through
some numerical experiments since uh
using up a little bit of time
so can i ask another question about the
previous thing
so the the training data is of
polynomial size right yes it's soft
okay so this classical algorithm with
polynomial size data
is solving an np-hard problem or
no it's not really because it's for any
smooth class that have a training data
i think that's also maybe what ryan
o'donnell was asking
um it's not like uh with with just
one set of training data and then now
you can solve all hamiltonian it's all
it could only solve a smooth class
within that smooth squat sometime i told
you
so basically if you have same system
size but maybe there could be multiple
different smooth class
then you would need training data for
different smooth class so maybe like
different quantum phase so you have one
quantum phase another quantum phase
you get data for this quantum phase um
and then the machinery model could
predict within this quantum phase
but if you have a different quantum
phase then you need data for that as
well
so and there there's potentially a large
number of different smooth skies of
local hamiltonians for a fixed system
size
and yeah so
and does the problem remain hard if you
fix the smooth class
uh
i mean but if you fix a smooth content
that's also if you fix your system size
so then
it's not i mean that there's no
dependence on
them going so
so yeah so i'm not sure how yeah
maybe it means if there's like one
smooth class for each value of n
oh but then but yeah but then you can
always pick it
in some weird way like if you yeah like
if you define it such that you have one
smooth class for each value of n
you can always pick the the the smooth
sky such that this function becomes
undecidable
and then it just becomes hard
like you can pick it in some way so you
maybe if you pick it in a polynomial way
like
like you can pick the smooth class um
for each
value of n and that could be
selected using a polynomial time
classical algorithm
then that is a situation i'm not
entirely sure what is the complexity
of that so like if you only pick one of
them
um so yeah so
i think that's a reasonable one to
consider um
but in that case i'm not entirely sure
if that's still hard or
it's a it could still be hard at least
that's what i found
um but it might be easy so it could be
the case that
if the insert of given data if the
classical algorithm was just somehow
told what the smooth class is i don't
know how this would
be done but like so say the smooth
classes had a name or something and
given this information then the
classical article might be able to solve
this in polynomial time without
training data so that i'm not sure
so that i'm actually not sure because i
think it depends on whether there are
sparse languages
and i mean i think it depends on whether
there are sparse languages that's
not in that's that's not in
bpp but an mp
which i don't i i try to check that but
i think there's no answer
for that one yet so there could be
hard problems but yeah it depends on
this
like the yeah this study about sparse
languages
in order to properly answer that
question but i've also thought about it
but
i haven't found a like a clear
uh unambiguous answer to that yet
so that's a good question thanks
yeah so now here uh i'll just quickly
show
some of the numerical experiments that
we consider so here we consider a
one-dimensional ripper
array and then we train a machine
learning model on a training set of only
20 points
to predict the ground state for other
points so it's also
this one is also simpler so the
parameter space is only two dimensional
and then we have all these randomly
sampled training data shown as a gray
circle and now we're just trying to
train the ml model such that it could
predict the ground state for the entire
space
particularly we test them on these three
points shown here
that yeah and then here are the
prediction
the black markers are the prediction
from ml model and the
solid lines are the exact values
computed by performing a time consuming
dmrg
and you can show that in matchups pretty
well on the other hand
if you consider a very naive strategy
where for each of the testing point you
just pick the closest point
in the training set and then just say oh
the ground states that you can see that
it performs much worse
than training a proper machine learning
model
similar situation also holds when we
consider predicting ground safe for a
two-dimensional
system so this is a three-dimensional
random heisenberg model
where the ground state is pretty
challenging to solve so we're doing some
kind of a
snake shape dmrg which would scale
exponentially in the width
um so yeah and then
and then here are the prediction um uh
this is the prediction from ml model
it's a prediction of two-point
correlation function from ml model
and this is the exact values from the
mig and visually it's pretty similar
there are indeed some small amount of
error prediction error
inside of it visually you can see that
it's pretty close in practice
and we're actually only using an equal
to 100 number of training set
so in practice it actually performs much
better than our theoretical guarantee
because actually in the theorem um this
when i say
n is polynomial in m for a fixed
epsilon so let's say you fix epsilon to
be 0.1 when i say this polynomial it's
actually m to the power of maybe
a few thousand or a few few millions so
it's not really
efficient from a practical perspective
but when you actually run it
it's much better than our theoretical
guarantee has
so now after talking about the the
second part i'm predicting ground state
um i'll just quickly storm through the
part on
classifying quantum phases of matter so
here the task is much more well studied
basically given a quantum state you
wanted to predict which quantum phases
of matter the state
is in and we again represent the quantum
state using this classical shadow
representation
so here similarly we're going to
consider a training set
telling you that oh for this cost core
presentation of the quantum state
this is the associated phase and for
that classification of the ground state
that is the associated phase and so on
and now after training on this training
set
the machine learning model has to
predict for a new state
what is this phase it's a trivial phase
simply broken phase topological order
phase and so on
essentially what the ml model would do
is they would try to find it
basically what the ml model should do is
it would try to find some classifying
function that could well separate the
phase of matter
so for example if you consider symmetry
broken phase there's typically a local
observer
o that can be used to classify between
the two phases
in that case the classical model only
needs to learn a linear function which
is very easy
by training a linear classifier however
if you just utilize
this simple ml model um to try to
classify more exotic phases such as a
topological face
then preposition two prevented in our
paper shows that it's impossible
so basically if you have two distinct
typological phase
there's no global and there's no local
as well as global observable
that exists that could be used to
classify between the two so this is a
basic consequence of the definition of
the topological phase
but this proposition is kind of
interesting um
so now basically what it says is that we
need a much more powerful ml model
that could learn non-linear function for
example some quadratic function or a
more generic
a more general analytic function in
order to do so
we're going to utilize the standard
technique in kernel methods
we're just going to learn a linear
function in an infinite dimensional
space
where we map each state rho to an
infinite dimensional vector
given here that includes all the
our body reduced density matrices as
well as
higher degree expansion of these reduced
density matrices
so we are called this feature vector phi
shadow
so training such a so basically what
we're going to do is we're going to
learn a linear function
in this expanded infinite dimensional
feature space
which will be equivalent to learning a
non-linear function in the original
quantum state
rule and all we need to do um basically
in order to efficiently train that
is to be able to compute the inner
product and the inner product could
actually be evaluated efficiently
through some algebraic manipulation you
can see that the inner product could be
given by this
double exponential formula
um and computing this thing which we
refer to as shadow kernel
only takes time linear in system size
and quadratic in
the number of randomized measurement we
perform
t squared so actually training such a
classical ml model
could be extremely efficient in practice
and we also give a rigorous guarantee
for it we showed that if there exists a
non-linear function of fuel body reduced
and c-matrix that could be used to
classify the phases
then this classical algorithm that we
discussed basically learning a linear
function in this infinite dimensional
space
could learn to classify this phases
accurately and the amount of training
time
training data and computational time
with both scales polynomially and system
size
furthermore this ml model would
construct this classifying function
efficiently
exclusively such that it could help
physicists to better understand the
phase traction
and in various cases which i listed here
there does exist
classifying functions that acts only on
fuel body reduced sensing matrices
if you assume a constant spectral gap
for the state that you're looking at
that is its associated hamiltonian has a
constant spectrograph
and what the theorem two is saying is
that as long as this classifying
function exists
then the machine learning model
utilizing the shadow kernel is
guaranteed to find it
similar situation um it also works
pretty well in practice
which we show here so here we consider a
one-dimensional symmetry protected
topological base
so this is a one-dimensional spin chain
called the bound alternating xxc model
which exhibits three different phases
and
what we're going to do is slightly
different from what we proved
because i mean we already proved that it
would work so now we're going to
consider a harder
task for the numerical experiment we're
going to consider doing it on
supervisedly
so you don't have a label training data
you're only given a bunch of states and
now the machine learning model has to
figure out
what are the states and how the states
form into phases
and essentially how we do that is
still utilizing this feature map this
shadow feature map that we define
that maps a quantum state so basically
what it does is it maps the quantum
state into a
classical shadow and then utilize that
classical shadow to define this
infinite dimensional feature vector into
infinite dimensional space
and what this uh unsurvived ml model is
doing is it's looking at the infinite
dimensional
vector space a huber space and then just
finding
a low dimensional subspace that have the
largest separation
of the data points and here in c and d
are the two dimensional subspace that
the unsurvived machine learning model
finds
and you can see that for for c
we consider delta equal to 0.5 which
only consists of two phases
here so you can see that it figure out
that there's two phases
and for delta equal to 3.0 there's three
phases
and the machinery model figures out the
three phases
and similar situation also holds for a
two-dimensional topologically overfaced
you can train this some supervised
machine learning model to classify
between
a topological phase consisting of states
where we start from the target of grass
state and apply a constant dapps random
stricken on top of it
and a trivial phase which consists of
product saved and applying a constant
depth
random circuit on top of it
so here in figure c we show the
classification accuracy that is
we use the service machine learning
model to cluster it and then
check how that works and the green line
is essentially the
performance of the unsupervised machine
learning model so when the when the
dapps you applied
is low like it's constant apps then
the performance is pretty well but when
you increase the depth
then the two phases will become more and
more indistinguishable
and then in that case the two phases
would just be collapsed
and that's also what the machine
learning model figures out on its own
we also compare it with convolution
neural network which is a model that
people have considered before
and which would be actually be you can
prove that it'll be equivalent to trying
to learn
an observable for classifying
topological phases
and since we already proved that there's
no observable that could be used to
classify phases
um this purple line just a convolutional
neural network is deemed to foul
and you can see that after just applying
a single
random circuit depth it just drops to
0.5 accuracy
which is equivalent to just performing
random guessing
so now to conclude we proved that
classical ml models
informed by data from physical
experiments could effectively address
some quantum many antibody problems in
particular as a consequence of theorem 1
and proposition 1
we rigorously establish advantage of
classical ml models over classical
non-ml algorithms
so more generally just classical
algorithms that doesn't have access to
data i think that should be more precise
and some of the interesting open
questions include what are some
advantage
of ml over non-ml algorithms that is
whether
learning from data would be helpful in
other kinds of tasks potentially other
quantum tests
or maybe some classical tests not sure
can we also establish advantage in other
tasks
and the second question is we also
approve rigorous guarantee for
other kinds of quantum problems
utilizing classical machine learning
algorithms
and finally another twist on what i was
talking about
you can think of it as providing a very
strong baseline
for quantum machine learning algorithms
essentially people have been thinking
about using quantum machine learning
algorithms like predicting ground states
or
maybe classifying phases more on
classified phases
um essentially what this work says is
that
for those kind of tasks it's kind of
already very easy for classical machine
learning algorithms too
so the advantage you would get from
using proper quantum machine learning
algorithm
would also be limited despite them being
a very quantum mechanical
problem so could we actually find a
useful class of quantum
learning problems with exponential point
advantage is still a big
yeah it's a very important open question
to further address
and actually um me and jordan and sitan
chen
and jerry lee have made some progress
and for the last question
where jordan would actually provide a
presentation in the talk
after the next so that's it for my talk
thank you so much for listening
thanks for your talk robert we have a
couple minutes for questions so does
anyone have any questions
um
yes you mean you mean the first first
few slides
yeah yeah so
i i guess i would expect the uh
sorry i think i i wasn't i couldn't hear
it properly
i mean so so the shadow is is a total of
outcomes that where each of them
um
oh you mean the expectation value of
this
all right one of the products is
sorry i think uh maybe my internet is
not good i'm gonna hear
very clearly um so so one but one thing
to
to emphasize is that the sigma are
actually not product state
they're they're actually they're
actually not possibly semi-definite
and actually this this whole
representation is not positive
semi-definite
that's why i always refer it to uh just
a matrix it's not a quantum state
um because all of these sigma actually
have negative eigenvalues
and that's why you get this um if all of
these are just like
for example if rho is a pure state and
then all of these are just like
product states i mean are just like also
quantum state then the tensor product of
them is
the quantum state and when you average
over them that would be mixed
so then this equation would not hold
so actually the reason that this
equation holds is indeed because all of
these sigma
are um have negative eigenvalues they're
actually
have some positive and negative
i hope uh is that the confusion right
is that the question uh uh yeah so i
guess my question was
like when you randomize the
individual poly measurements each of
them is a
you know bound bounded by one each of
them is random so like if you're
measuring
serotonin you have all these
independents
yes
oh they would actually not be
independent because for for this sigma
ones is sigma n
they're performed by doing a parallel
measurement so so there will be
correlation between different sigmas
so that's how you capture some
entanglement properties using this
formalism
hello sorry okay okay so let's think
about it again
okay
[Applause]